on the streets in the homes
and behind the wheels of this country
there's a cost to bear of a far away
conflict great yarmouth is it man
higher energy bills higher prices at the
pump higher pressure on us all
especially those who drive for a living
in the last couple of months it seems to
have crept up in the last week
it seems to have raced up the costs of
going to work have never been anywhere
near as high and the energy bills
are frightening you're sort of running
from one to the other and trying to keep
the cost down on all of them
and struggling
it's caused by high costs of oil and gas
processed in refineries like this
crucially the uk buys very little from
russia but europe buys a lot it means
any disruption pushes prices right up
prices across the whole market
and it affects more than just the cost
of heating our homes it's also biting
here the tanks which we're now in front
of here
hold about seven and a half thousand
tons each
where fertilizer arrives is turned
around and sold on
mammoth tanks of the stuff made using
gas destined for the fields of our
farmers
a huge part to play in the price of our
food prices for nitrogen fertilizers
have gone up by three or four hundred
percent in the last year and that was
without the war because we're at the
start of the food chain what we pay
passed on to farmers and in turn to
consumers is going to hit everybody in
the pocket it means that we're on the
path to the three pound loaf of bread
the seven pound pint
this conflict has underlined a difficult
reality you don't need to be a buyer of
russian gas to be highly vulnerable to
its impact on the price and the
consequences are vast and already
pressing question is now urgent how do
we reduce our reliance on that gas and
reduce it quickly
so what is the answer well some say it
lies underground here not moving away
from gas but extracting our own fracking
for it in the north of england
but for now it's banned for safety
reasons this former site lies still and
unused a huge failure says the boss in
energy policy and planning even if you
were fracking for british gas that
wouldn't affect the price would it
because you'd still sell it at market
price it may well affect the price we've
got to be able to do it more cheaply
than taking shale gas from the united
states putting it on a boat sailing
across the atlantic you know people are
saying well that will make a difference
because it doesn't affect prices
tomorrow well the reason we're in this
mess is because we haven't thought about
this
you know 10 years ago the only real
shield is alternative sources nuclear
solar or wind
but all are still too fledgling to cover
demand
energy security is not just about supply
it's about supply that's affordable if
russia turned off the taps we'd still be
able to turn on the lights but at what
cost and for how long
helen ann smith sky news in great
yarmouth